[Musique]
je 18 minutes pour vous parler de mon
expérience du jeune et d'accompagnement
de jeunes heures c'est trop facile
alors j'ai décidé de relever le défi en
18 secondes
oui alors je vais vous donner cinq
points points clés sur le jeune le jeune
nous permet d'aller à l'essentiel et
nous invite à relever de nouveaux défis
il nous conduit à vivre une aventure
intérieure
il nous fait prendre conscience que
seule l'expérience nous amène à la
connaissance et enfin le jeûne est une
expérience du vide qui nous remplit
voilà les 18 secondes sont terminées
maintenant je blague bien sûr je vais
faire comme mes petits camarades
et je vais vous parler pendant 18
minutes enfin 17 parce que là il ya déjà
une minute d'écoulée
depuis des millénaires dans toutes les
traditions dans toutes les cultures
on a pu observer des restrictions
alimentaires qui étaient liés soit au
respect des préceptes religieux soit
simplement un manque de nourriture en
occident nous vivons dans l'abondance et
nous n'avons aucune raison de nous
priver de nourriture
enfin en apparence quand nous observons
nos enfants qui sont malades
naturellement ils cessent de manger
parce que je crois qu'ils ont conservé
un instinct de guérison que nous perdons
ensuite à l'âge adulte
je voudrais rendre un hommage aux
pratiquants du jeûne de 40 jours à
certains en tout cas d'abord dans
l'antiquité
hippocrate le père de la médecine et
puis socrates qui discours est en
jeûnant et en marchant pythagore
qu'imposait delon jeune à ses futurs
élèves
et puis aussi bien sûr un gandhi qui a
inauguré le jeune politique
je voudrais rendre aussi un hommage aux
deux millions d'allemands qui jeunes
chaque année en effet chez nos voisins
cette pratique est très courante
elle peut même être remboursé par le
système de santé
est ce que vous savez quelle est la
question qui m'est le plus souvent posée
et bien c'est ok vous jeûnez mais
pendant le jeune qu'est ce que vous
mangez
si si je vous assure on me demande ça
tout le temps
ben justement c'est quoi se nourrir
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on va qu'on va
ressentir le fait d'être nourris est ce
que c'est parce qu'on est rassasié plein
en vie plein de vie et pourquoi dans
notre culture on réduit toujours le fait
d'être nourris au fait de manger moi si
je réduis le fait d'être nourri
seulement au fait de manger je me sens
comme amputé pas vraiment entière allez
je vous raconte alors ça se passe il ya
tout juste 16 ans je rentre chez moi un
soir je n'avais ni petit déjeuner ni
déjeuner et je suis affamé j'ai vraiment
une faim de loup alors je me précipite
dans la cuisine j'ouvre frénétiquement
un placard jean sort un paquet de
biscuits jeu louvre
le déchirent littéralement je
m'engouffre le contenu non en fait je
les exécute
c'est vraiment ça et puis j'entends une
petite voix intérieure qui me dit
valérie aujourd'hui c'était la dernière
fois que tu tant pis ferais tu vas
trouver des moyens pour te libérer de
ses compulsions alimentaires
il te faut un déclic alors j'ai deux
amis je ne veux qu'ils me pousse à
partir dans la drôme faire un jeûne et
randonnée chez les bling qui sont les
pionniers du jeûne et randonnée en
france ce qui est très étrange c'est que
dès le premier jour je me sens bien je
ne ressens absolument pas la fin et même
je pourrais dire que je me sens nourrit
comme si le simple fait d'être connecté
à la nature pouvait me nourrir alors
c'est une sensation que j'ai déjà
rencontré en randonnant sauf qu ici j'y
vois une dimension supplémentaire
c'est inhabituel c'est comme si
habituellement je vis des aventures à
l'extérieur et pendant cette première
expérience du jeune je vis une aventure
à l'intérieur et puis très vite je sais
que moi aussi je vais accompagner des
jeûneurs randonneurs c'est une évidence
j'aime la nature je suis sportive j'aime
la randonnée la montagne j'en connais un
rayon sur l'alimentation
et puis je suis sophrologue et j'ai
l'habitude d'accompagner d'accompagner
des groupes
pim pam poum la graine est planté
et puis mon expérience de vie m'amène à
ressentir un besoin vital de transmettre
alors la première idée que je veux vous
transmettre c'est en reconsidérant une
croyance que vous avez peut-être est-ce
que vous croyez vraiment que pour
pratiquer une activité physique
il faut que vous ayez mangée auparavant
et bien moi je vous invite à croire le
contraire
quand vous mangez on pourrait dire que
en quelque sorte vous êtes en mode
majeur quand vous jeûnez vous êtes en
mode jeûneurs en fait le métabolisme est
différent c'est comme si le programme
est différent
et puis si vous pratiquez cette activité
en dehors de de vos repères habituels
dans un groupe
vous allez ressentir une émulation et ça
va vous aider à vivre l'expérience ça
sera plus facile et plus riches
et contrairement aux idées reçues le
jeune peut se vivre dans le plaisir et
dans la joie je vous assure tant que
vous ne l'avez pas vécu vous n'avez
aucune idée de ce qui pourrait se passer
pour vous
la deuxième idée que je veux vous
transmettre c'est réfléchissais depuis
toujours depuis que vous avez été conçu
dans le ventre de votre mère vous êtes
nourrit depuis l'extérieur
quand vous venez vous ne mangez pas
cependant vous êtes nourris quand même
trop fort vous aller puiser dans vos
réserves recycler des microbes des
cellules des tissus et c'est ça qui va
vous nourrir vous allez vous auto
restaurer dans tous les sens du terme
je peux vous citer quelques
améliorations qui peuvent survenir
pendant qu'on jeunes en tout cas des
améliorations physiques alors on peut
parler d'une baisse de la tension
artérielle et du cholestérol un
apaisement des inflammations comme
l'arthrite par exemple un renforcement
des défenses immunitaires une
amélioration des pathologies digestives
et de la peau ainsi que une amélioration
de tout ce qui touche la sphère orl
prenons une métaphore imaginons une
alarme
quand elle sonne c'est parce qu'elle
était réglé programmé pour vous prévenir
voire vous protéger d'un danger éventuel
ou réel est bien dans votre corps il se
passe exactement la même chose et quand
vous venez vous allez faire l'expérience
d'une relation plus intime avec votre
corps vous allez coopérer avec lui et à
chaque fois qu'il va vous envoyer un
signal comme celui de la larme comme par
exemple des maux de tête
un rhume une crise de foi une cystite un
eczéma
à chaque fois c'est pour vous avertir
qu'il faut agir que vous avez quelque
chose a changé dans votre comportement
même et ce message qu'il vous envoie
imaginer que c'est une sentinelle
bienveillante qui vous l'envoie
entendez aussi que un médecin ou un
thérapeute peut vous soigner vous êtes
la seule personne à pouvoir vous guérir
quelque chose de très important aussi
qui se passe pendant le jeûne c'est que
vous allez faire une expérience
d'autonomie à chaque fois que vous
recommencez l'expérience du jeune c'est
comme si vous coupiez à nouveau le
cordon ombilical et qu'est ce que vous
croyez qu'il peut se passer si vous vous
sentez plus autonome peut-être que vous
allez vous sentir plus libre voire plus
heureux et cette expérience d'autonomie
et fantastique parce que de l'état de
victimes de la maladie
vous allez passer à l'état deux acteurs
de votre santé et ça change tout
vous allez avoir une nouvelle conscience
des choses vous allez pouvoir libérer
des tensions psychique et émotionnel et
vous allez vivre une expérience qui sera
quelque chose de complètement à
soupçonner vous allez avoir une relation
totalement différente avec vos cinq sens
comme si c'était plus affûtés plus
aiguisée on peut prendre l'exemple de
l'odorat vous allez avoir une perception
des parfums beaucoup plus subtil et puis
quand vous allez remanger il va se
passer quelque chose de l'ordre d'un
enchantement ou d'un feu d'artifice à on
parle même d'une extase des papilles
on peut prendre l'exemple aussi de de ce
qui se passe avec la vue vous allez
avoir une acuité au niveau des
contrastes des couleurs différentes
j'ai une personne de mon entourage qui
un jour m'a envoyé son mari pour jeûner
et quand il est rentré chez c'est chez
elle chez eux
voici ce qu'elle m'a écrit valérie je te
remercie d'avoir accompagné michel mon
mari je retrouve un homme plus jeune de
dix ans et sans lunettes
en effet le jeune à la capacité
d'augmenter la régénération de
l'organisme
et puis vous allez aussi rencontré
beaucoup de sérénité une paire
d'intérieurs vous aurez les idées plus
claires
c'est d'ailleurs un très bon moment pour
prendre des décisions une meilleure
estime de vous même plus confiance en
vous c'est comme si vous pouvez aller à
l'essentiel être aligné et aussi plus
d'altruisme
et puis j'aime bien parler du jeune dans
ces termes
moi quand je vis le jeune c'est comme si
j'avais une remontée de la seine comme
si j'ai une montée du désir mais pas
seulement le désir sexuel le désir en
général c'est vraiment un moment où j'ai
envie de me lancer dans de nouveaux
projets c'est un moment où on connecte
on a une connexion très forte avec nos
intuitions
pendant le jeûne aussi vous allez
dépasser une croyance très forte ne
croyais à une croyance de base
cette croyance et si je ne mange pas je
vais mourir de faim une fois que cette
croyance qui était jusque-là gravé dans
votre adn est dépassé elle va vous
permettre d'avoir les landes en dépasser
bien d'autres bien d'autres et c'est
comme si c'est un processus qui
s'enclenche
savoir n'est pas connaître je vous
propose de faire une petite expérience
tous ensemble là dans la salle
vous êtes d'accord alors on dirait qu'on
serait sur une planète et sur cette
planète
personne d'entre nous n'aurait jamais vu
une pomme on dirait ça d'accord
maintenant je vais vous expliquer ce
qu'est une pomme écoutez bien alors la
pomme est un fruit sucré acide
elle a des propriétés astringentes qui
sont différentes en fonction des
variétés
il en existe 20 millions de variétés
elle est le fruit cultivé le plus
consommé en france est le troisième dans
le monde on peut la consommer crue cuite
ou séchées on peut en tirer aussi du jus
et lorsqu'il est fermenté il prend la
dénomination de cidre normalement là
tout le monde sait ce que c'est qu'une
pomme bien sûr
savoir n'est pas connaître et moi est ce
que je sais ce que c'est qu'une pomme et
si je la goutte est
elle est bonne en plus en
et bien moi je crois sincèrement que
dans cette salle sur cette planète
je suis la seule
qui sait ce qu'est une pomme
voulez-vous un goûter
[Applaudissements]